[Applause]
[Music]
there's a distinctive youthful feel to
this year's honors list eleven-year-old
tobias weller known as the captain in
his hometown of sheffield raised more
than
157 000 pounds during the pandemic he
wanted to help others with cerebral
palsy and autism and says he's chuffed
to bits to be the youngest person on
record to receive the british empire
medal
my man my man tell me about the
on on jerusalem's day and i thought wow
i'm actually gonna get another
her majesty
the queen the queen
i am so excited
2021 was also the year science fought
back against covid and in recognition
the medical chiefs leading the battle
have been honoured professor chris witte
his deputy jonathan van tam and the
welsh and scottish counterparts will all
receive knighthoods
it's been such a delight to work with
chris and my colleagues in northern
ireland michael mcbride and gregor smith
up in scotland you know and it's it's
actually brought us together as chief
medical officers across the four nations
in total one in five of the new year's
honors are related to kovid
including a knighthood for sky news's
trevor phillips his work with data
company weber phillips was the first to
examine the effect of covid on different
cultural and ethnic groups
we've brought
science in particular in my case data
science to bear in understanding
what
differences really mean in our society
and we saw last year that covid really
had a differential impact according to
who you were where you came from where
you lived
kovit also brought testing times to the
world of sport in 2021 under strict
conditions the tokyo olympics finally
went ahead with team gb lifting the
spirits of the nation with some
outstanding performances those who took
gold will be honored by the queen
including cyclists laura and jason kenny
who will receive a dame and
they're thought to be the first married
couple to be honoured at the same time
and teenage tennis sensation emma
radicanu ends the year with another
title to her growing collection after
being given an mbe
other famous british faces awarded
include actress joanna lumley who'll be
made a dame and after his final outing
is james bond daniel craig has been made
a companion of the order of saint
michael and saint george a special
diplomatic honor also given to his
fictional character double07
[Music]
in what has been a challenging year the
new year's honors list recognises all
those we've entertained and inspired and
led the way in uncertain times
charlotte lomas sky news